-Performing "Left and Right" and "Loser"
from his new album, "Charlie," once again, Charlie Puth.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ Memories follow me left and right ♪
♪ I can feel you over here, I can feel you over here ♪
♪ You take up every corner of my mind ♪
♪ What you gonna do now? ♪
♪ Ever since the day you went away ♪
♪ No, I don't know how ♪
♪ How to erase your body from out my brain ♪
♪ What you gonna do now? ♪
♪ Maybe I should just focus on me instead ♪
♪ But all I think about ♪
♪ Are the nights we were tangled up in your bed ♪
♪ Oh, no, oh, no ♪
♪ We're goin' 'round in circles ♪
♪ Got you stuck up in my head, yeah ♪
♪ Memories follow me left and right ♪
♪ I can feel you over here, I can feel you over here ♪
♪ You take up every corner of my mind ♪
♪ Your love stays with me day and night ♪
♪ I can feel you over here, I can feel you over here ♪
♪ You take up every corner of my mind ♪
♪ What you gonna do now? ♪
♪♪
[ Segue into "Loser" ]
♪ Oh, I'm such a loser ♪
♪ How'd I ever lose her? ♪
♪ Ooh, maybe I must have been out of my mind ♪
♪ Now I'm a loser ♪
♪ Why'd I have to lose her? ♪
♪ I'll never recover, I'll never be fine ♪
♪ I just might get a little too drunk ♪
♪ So I don't think about us ♪
♪ I don't think about what we could have been ♪
♪ And I stay up like three or four nights ♪
♪ So I don't dream about us ♪
♪ Wake up with no luck ♪
♪ I just can't win ♪
♪ Should have seen it all along ♪
♪ She was one in a million ♪
♪ It hurts whenever someone says her name ♪
-♪ Says her name ♪
-♪ We were going off and on ♪
♪ I guess I really played it wrong ♪
♪ Should have never let her slip away ♪
♪ Oh, I'm such a loser ♪
♪ How'd I ever lose her? ♪
♪ Ooh, maybe I must have been out of my mind ♪
♪ Now I'm a loser ♪
♪ Why'd I have to lose her? ♪
♪ I'll never recover, I'll never be fine ♪
♪ 'Cause I ♪
♪ I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm, I ♪
♪ I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm gonna lose her ♪
♪ Say ♪
♪ I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm, I ♪
♪ I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm a loser ♪
♪ Tell me, God is real ♪
♪ Do you think about me still? ♪
♪ Or am I living for nothing? ♪
♪ Don't know where it went wrong ♪
♪ But I'll just take the hint ♪
♪ It's gonna take some adjusting ♪
♪ Oh, I'm such a loser ♪
♪ How'd I ever lose her? ♪
♪ Ooh, maybe I must have been out of my mind ♪
♪ Loser, why'd I have to lose her? ♪
♪ I'll never recover, I'll never be fine ♪
♪ 'Cause I'm a loser ♪
♪ I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm, I ♪
[ Vocalizing ]
♪ Oh, I say ♪
♪ I say, I'm a loser ♪
[ Cheers and applause ] -Come on, now!